et pour en parler avec nous sur ce
plateau christophe prat secrétaire
fédéral fo cheminots bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous plusieurs
syndicats de la ratp et la sncf ont donc
appelé à une journée morte aujourd'hui
dans les transports dans les transports
le trafic est pourtant peu perturbé
aujourd'hui comment est-ce que vous
l'analysez oui il ya eu un appel
aujourd'hui d'une journée on va dire
symbolique c'est ça avait déjà été le
cas au mois de septembre
ça avait été un petit peu un
avertissement lancé aux gouvernements
face à cette réforme des retraites
et puis la grève a démarré le 5 décembre
aujourd'hui un appel sur une journée
morte comme vous l'avez dit c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué à réaliser sur
une journée oui à moins de perturbations
puisque il ya des trains en réserve
il ya des personnels qui sont pas
forcément en grève donc on va dire que
le trafic n'est pas complètement arrêté
pour autant on sait que la mobilisation
est assez forte aujourd'hui et fo
cheminots que vous représentez donc
tente de reproduire la force de la grève
qui s'est engagé le 5 décembre ce sont
les termes malgré tout c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de mobiliser ses dix fils
est toujours difficile de mobiliser et
notamment par la grève
quand on a aujourd'hui on va dire dans
les pattes
plus de deux mois et demi de grève pour
certains personnels ça ça pose question
en tout cas pour les conséquences de la
grève c'est-à-dire les retenues
financières voulais dire à la fois que
l'été sur ce plateau on a des fiches de
paye qui tombe en ce moment à 0 il ya
forcément des contraintes pour autant la
détermination est intacte c'est à dire
que l'ensemble des personnels que ce
soit dans les transports à la sncf à la
ratp dans les enseignants et tous les
corps de métiers qui sont mobilisées
contre cette réforme
ils sont toujours très déterminés à
faire échec à ce projet aujourd'hui
débute donc à partir de 16h à
l'assemblée nationale au sein de
l'hémicycle en séance plénière à
l'examen du projet de loi de réforme des
retraites comment est ce que vous
comptez peser sur les débats
parlementaires
alors est ce qu'il ya un an qu est-ce
que vous avez encore l'espoir de pouvoir
faire évoluer le texte oui
c'est aussi le symbole de cette journée
c'était donc l'entrée un petit peu à
l'assemblée de l'étude du texte à
l'assemblée nationale
comment on pèse aujourd'hui on compte
sur le retour à la raison du
gouvernement ça fait des mois qu'il fait
la sourde oreille aux mécontentements
ce qu'on attend d'un gouvernement c'est
qu'il écoute son peuple avant tout et
aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'il a fait la
sourde oreille qui l'a même fait
l'autruche et il fait semblant qu'il n'y
a pas de contestation dans ce pays alors
qu'elle est quand même massif elle est
même majoritaire dans l'opinion publique
il ya aujourd'hui des partis politiques
qui milite même dans le sens du retrait
de ce texte sous sa forme actuelle
donc le chemin de ce texte va faire son
oeuvre au niveau législatif pour autant
dans la rue il va être accompagné aussi
quand le mécontentement de tous ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui opposés
il n'est pas exclu que le gouvernement
ait recours au 49 3 pour faire passer en
force ce projet de loi qu'elle pourrait
être alors la réaction les organisations
syndicales et de fo cheminots
la réaction elle pourrait être elle
pourrait être en tout cas ce qu'elle a
été depuis le début c'est à dire
d'autant plus déterminés quand on écoute
pas
je vous dis de mécontentement il faut
s'attendre à une réaction
ils ont voulu faire taire la
contestation en faisant semblant que
c'était qu'une partie où c'était
certaines professions qui étaient
touchés n'ont aujourd'hui tout le monde
a bien connaissance que tout le monde
sera touché par cette réforme
donc passer en force savez quand on
n'arrive pas à convaincre
on passe en force on a même vu dans
certaines manifestations n'envoie la
matraque et c'est aujourd'hui le 49-3 ce
serait une forme de matraque
législatives et il ne pourrait y avoir
qu une réaction à la hauteur de
l'attaqué
donc je pense qu'il faut revenir à la
raison le secrétaire d'état aux
transports jean baptiste est djebbari
annoncé le coup de grève de décembre et
janvier pour la sncf à peu près un
milliard d'euros il a aussi annoncé un
plan d'économies sont suppressions de
postes prévues at il déclaré est ce que
malgré tout c'est un nouveau coup dur
pour vous non c'est pas un coup dur ça
va dans le droit fil des mêmes des
gouvernements précédents de la ligne
politique c'est la destruction des
services publics la sncf au 1er janvier
est devenue une société anonyme
ça fait des années des dizaines d'années
qu'on supprime des emplois la sncf et
dans d'autres entreprises pareil les
gouvernements il offre des millions en
subventions à des grands groupes dont la
sncf
carrefour et j'en passe pour créer des
emplois aujourd'hui n'ya pas d'emplois
qui sont créées il ya des emplois qui
sont détruits donc pour nous c'est par
un coup dur c'est juste une confirmation
des politiques qui sont menées c'est le
sait le tout argent c'est détruire de
l'emploi au lieu d'en créer
c'est ça qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui les
gens attendent aujourd'hui qu'on crée
des emplois qu'on facilite l'accès à
l'emploi des plus jeunes et qu'on agisse
pour maintenir les seniors dans l'emploi
aujourd'hui c'est tout l'inversé quels
faits ont détruit des emplois on baisse
les prestations chômage
il n'y a rien qui est fait dans le sens
du social est aujourd'hui la taxe sur
les retraites c'est la goutte d'eau
c'est aujourd'hui on veut faire
travailler les gens plus longtemps en
fait on veut les laisser plus longtemps
au chômage
c'est ça la vérité merci beaucoup d'être
à venir réagir sur notre plateau
christophe prat secrétaire fédéral fo
cheminots
merci